Madana what qualities does a modern
subcompact need to have of course it has
to be small says car tested I know the
Opel Karl is so small it barely takes up
half a normal parking space a subcompact
should also be modern and the Karl is
the only model in its class with
personal online and service assists the
system goes by the name OnStar it offers
a wide range of safety and comfort
features for example if a collision
triggers the airbag the system
automatically contacts the OnStar
service center which asks whether you
need help if you don't answer the center
immediately contacts local emergency
services
Opel's entry-level model was launched at
the end of 2014
the Carl maybe Oppo smallest car but it
doesn't have to hide behind its big
brother's backs the price is very
attractive the basic version costs 9500
euros in Germany and even this version
has the standard infotainment system
we tested the 1-liter 3-cylinder
gasoline engine version which produces
55 kilowatts and can take the car up to
170 km/h average fuel consumption is
under 5 liters per 100 kilometers all of
the carl's components have been designed
to minimize vibration and sound that
starts with the low resonance engine
block and continues with the split oil
pan the exhaust manifold which is
integrated in the cylinder head and
additional acoustic insulation on the
cam covers will design the 1 liter
3-cylinder engine especially for the
carl it's powerful enough for urban
traffic or country roads as Reinhold the
Carl has a surprisingly long list of
extras LED daytime running lights a Lane
Departure alert and for cold winters a
he-double leather steering wheel but the
latter is not standard it's part of the
comfort package which also offers a
parking assist and heated seats opel
charges 395 euros for the package the
seats in the top equipment version
innovation are made of a combination of
fabric and imitation leather
starting with the middle variant
addition D Carl has a city driving mode
press a button and maneuvering in city
traffic gets a lot simpler the
technology previously featured in Opel's
Adam and Corsa models the Carl has nice
handling - partly thanks to the cleverly
designed McPherson struts on the front
axle the springs are specially shaped to
partially compensate lateral forces this
engages the shock absorbers more
smoothly and also with less wear so they
have a longer operational life the
Carl's styling also shows that Opel is
trying to shed its dowdy image the best
thing about a subcompact for Reinhold is
when it doesn't feel small and the Carl
has enough room to transport five people
comfortably plus you have the perky
1-liter 3-cylinder engine and the state
of the art assists and safety systems
you